we're being taken down afghanistan's
back streets
to avoid the taliban's many armed
checkpoints
escorting us is the leader of the most
unlikely and bravest of rebels
they've already moved once after taliban
fighters ordered them to shut down
because these rebels are girls and
they're in a banned art class and no
taliban threats will deter them not even
in mid-winter with no heating
every girl here knows the dangers they
face if they're discovered
but they've tasted education and they've
judged the risk is worth it
it's because we're drawing women whose
faces aren't covered who aren't wearing
proper hijabs their teacher explains and
the taliban believe that's a big sin in
islam
the young women saw their studies halted
when the taliban took control nearly six
months ago
in an instant their dreams crumbled
i wanted to study hard and i wanted to
become a good politician for my country
one teenager tells me
but she quickly breaks down at just 14
she already knows that ambition is
simply not an option for her right now
and that is heartbreaking
the taliban are increasingly intolerant
of women's protests about their rights
the latest a week ago was broken up by
fighters using pepper spray
[Music]
and they didn't stop there
we've spoken to multiple witnesses who
saw the taliban raiding several homes
including this one rounding up the
female organizers
she managed to post this video as the
taliban came looking for her
help me the taliban hear she's crying
she and her three sisters were taken
away by armed men witnesses told us they
looked like taliban special forces the
girls haven't been seen since
others have also been targeted
the woman on the left arm raised leading
the chance has also been hunted down
she's seen on the march holding a
picture of world leaders including boris
johnson accusing them of silence over
afghanistan she's now on the run and in
hiding
her mother was at home with her
grandchildren when dozens of taliban
fighters forced their way in a few
nights ago looking for her daughter
i was shocked when i saw all these
taliban with guns and even rockets
inside my home she tells us
they pointed their guns at all of us
even the children i was so scared
we got a rare interview with one of the
taliban's most senior spokesman he's
part of the delegation to norway this
week that'll urge the world to lift
sanctions and he insisted the taliban
valued women
our security do not approach
women specifically because this is an
afghan society we have a lot of respect
for women we do not threaten women ever
can i show you a video of a young we
pull up tamanna's video with her
desperate cries for help
that video is uh of course distressing
the ministry of interior absolutely
rejected it and called the video fake
how is that fake
if it's fake where is the
approach the ministry of interior and
ask them how how they can came to that
conclusion
but we got no reply from the ministry
what you rightly pointed out of
terrifying women and children rousting
them from this from their sleep in the
dead of night
it happened for 20 years in afghanistan
foreign forces
would barge into homes
kill women and children torture their
men detain them take them to guantanamo
in bagram
that history is hard to forget but for
afghan women it looks like it's on
repeat and it's tough to witness
restrictions on dress most barred from
working and education in the face of an
economic collapse the most vulnerable
are suffering the most and they now need
a male relative escorting them on long
trips
but the first afghan woman to lead a
political party who spoke to us from
exile in britain insisted aid must be
contingent on women's
taliban rights of like giving them money
they need to pressurize them to listen
to a political dialogue
the sufferings everywhere children
begging for food and money mothers
pleading for scraps for their babies the
taliban say withholding aid is arbitrary
collective punishment for the whole
afghan people
it is the moral obligation of the
international community
to recognize the government that exists
which is a reality it is not going
anywhere anytime soon
and this government
has shown that it is a responsible actor
but while the taliban military are in
control and no country anywhere
recognizes their authority we found
afghan men blaming the international
community for imposing sanctions and
freezing afghan assets abroad and
causing more hardship
we're hurting he tells us we have
nothing and the money they've frozen
belongs to us it doesn't belong to any
government
but without some breakthrough afghans
are heading towards a full-blown
humanitarian disaster many would say
they're already in one
alex crawford sky news kabul